hey everyone i'm brie i'm a chef here in
la i have my own catering company in
business
and i've also worked for restaurants
like john and benny's broken spanish
botega louis and
beyond today i am tasked with tasting
and reviewing
some food items from mr beast's new fast
food delivery chain
not only is it unfathomable to even
think about
opening 300 restaurants in general as
just like
a person but to do it all
at once that's insane you don't get any
real feedback from people you don't see
what menu items work well
in what area what demographic you're
just rolling it
out
[Music]
i'm excited to get into everything and
taste it all and see what all the hype
is about
kind of looks like a whopper and i don't
know why
we're spongebob someone needs to get
spongebob in the kitchen because this is
not how you put a pickle on a burger
i'm sorry excuse me i'm just gonna get
into it it looks
good i'm not too happy with the bun even
for fast food you can get some decent
buns
we'll see
okay it's got some good flavor
there is spicy brown mustard on here
yes yes it is but it's good the meat's a
little dry though
but everything else is really flavorful
so kind of makes up for that i've had
better fast food burgers would i
recommend trying it out
for the sake of seeing what the hype is
about if you're into it sure
let's move on to the next i'm like
bffs with everyone who works at hal and
ray's those are my boys i am so sad
they're closed but i love ordering them
through delivery services right now
i think i just say i have very high
hopes
and very high expectations when people
speak on nashville hot chicken
sandwiches like
they do them justice so i'm always
skeptical
to try it from others and even just
looking at it in the unwrapping
this doesn't look like it's going to be
hot especially nashville hot
look at my little bun okay there's
pickles there's hope
that's dry they taste like
amusement park chicken tenders with just
like bam here's the dash this the dash
of that and like
salt based sprinkle of this like there's
not much to them
i would not recommend trying this
especially
calling it a nashville hot chicken
sandwich
how dare you how dare you
this is asheville because it's ashy and
dry i'm sorry i
don't want to be rude but i'm being
honest
put my sleeves up on this one the cheese
was cheese in just the right ways and
my mouth kind of watered a little bit so
we're off so good start
i have good hopes for this it's a
grilled cheese you can't mess up a
grilled cheese right
it's a grilled cheese with with american
cheese
i thought that tells you everything you
need to know it's it's good it's melted
it's warm it's cheesy if i'm gonna be
nitpicky
i wish there was like a little butter on
the buns that would just set it off
but this is actually the best thing i've
had so far i would totally recommend
this
of the three um it is definitely the
best choice it delivers on exactly what
it's supposed to be
and it's actually pretty decent i feel
like you're going with your kids your
kid will love this
all right so this might be the one i am
most excited to try
it is the beast style fries these onions
are raw
these are not caramelized onions i feel
deceived and i'm no longer as excited as
i was before i opened this
but i'm still gonna eat them and hope
they're delicious
i'm gonna try to get a bite that has
a little bit of everything a pickle
delicious i don't
dislike the raw onions these are
definitely obviously frozen fries
that they just um sprinkled some
seasoning on
and this is actually i can tell this is
the exact same seasoning that they put
on their nashville hot chicken
i'm picturing the kitchen cabinets now
just filled with that one seasoning
bottle
and one box of kosher salt i really
doubt they're making any of this from
scratch
obviously 300
anyway obviously they're gonna cut some
corners
but it's decent for what it is
they only charge five bucks for this
so i can't be too mad at that
final thoughts honestly it wasn't bad
i just wouldn't get it again it was nice
to say i've tried it i've had it
i'd rather go to burgers 99 down the
street and get an amazing smash burger
instead that's really good quality
supporting a nice local business and
people who actually know what they're
doing and are passionate about what
they're doing
i could taste the lack of passion and
love in this food yes it's fast food but
still
there should be a little bit of love in
there and it was missing that
so it was it was okay
[Music]
you